Again, as many of you know, I like Bernie
Sanders a lot.
I think he has great policies.
He's one of the most progressive candidates
running along with Elizabeth Warren.
I'd be thrilled for Bernie Sanders to be the
Democratic nominee and take on Donald Trump.
But when people I like do something I disagree
with, I say it and Bernie Sanders has made
a major mistake and naming a woman named Linda
Sarsour as a campaign surrogate.
Now I know I'm going to get crushed for this
by a sliver of the left.
People may cancel paid memberships, they'll
be angry that I have the audacity to call
out a woman who happens to be Muslim identity
politics argument.
But I am making the effort not to self-censor
and I just see this as a mistake.
Linda Sarsour is from the toxic wing of the
American left.
She, uh, is someone who has played coy with
and refused to denounce antisemitic nation
of Islam leader Louis Farrakhan.
She is someone who has participated in marginalizing
Jewish women in her role as founder of the
women's March, which I've previously talked
about.
I don't believe Bernie Sanders should have
anything to do with Linda Sarsour.
This is simply a mistake, plain and simple.
The Bernie campaign over the weekend tweeted
a video of Linda Sarsour speaking where she
is identified merely as a civil rights activist
and 2020 surrogate of Bernie Sanders.
But the truth is that she has a very, very
ugly past.
Again, Linda Sarsour is a founder of the women's
March.
She's one of the three founders I've told
you about before, along with Tamika Mallory
and Bob Bland, who allowed antisemitism to
pervade the movement, who didn't consider
Jewish women important to the movement and
marginalize them who played coy and Rick cozy
with antisemitic extremist nation of Islam
leader Louis Farrakhan, who I've widely denounced
before.
And it shouldn't be difficult.
Anyone who cares about civil rights and non-discrimination
and inclusion, no matter what your political
ideology is, you should just announced Louis
Farrakhan.
It shouldn't be difficult and Bernie should
have nothing to do with this.
And in fact, she has blamed white women for
the anti-abortion heartbeat bill that Georgia
tried to pass.
She has defended Sharia law in a series of
tweets trying to put a positive spin on it.
Other left and democratic groups have figured
this out.
For example, the DNC ended in support of the
women's March over exactly what I've described
to you before.
Having people like Linda Sarsour in the picture
is what hurts our own credibility.
I don't care about Linda Sarsour personally.
Uh, this is about what this does to the movement
to have people like this involved.
Even on the Israeli Palestinian conflict.
It quite frankly, it doesn't seem like Linda
Sarsour and Bernie Sanders are on the same
page.
Bernie has repeated many times when Israel
is attacked by rockets.
It has a right to defend itself.
He makes clear he's not going to play the
demonization games that lots of people like
Belinda Sar sewer play, we just don't need
them.
All of the productive views that Linda Sarsour
might hold are held by plenty of people who
aren't toxic and who aren't associated with
people like Louis Farrakhan.
She wants Medicare for all.
Great, so do I.
She wants tuition free college and a $15 minimum
wage.
Lots of people on the left do.
There's no reason to make her a surrogate
for Bernie Sanders.
It's not my left.
I'm actually surprised.
This is even something that Bernie Sanders
would entertain given his track record.
He may simply have no idea what's going on
with Linda Sarsour, but I would encourage
the left not to dabble with this toxic wing
because there is literally no upside.
There is no policy upside.
There's no ideological upside.
There's no public relations upside.
Even if you don't personally find Linda Sarsour
problematic, even though I believe that you
should, there is no strategic argument to
be made for her involvement and Bernie Sanders
campaign.
Period.
Now, if you disagree with me, let me know,
but try to do it in a way that's respectful,
right?
Let's, let's see if you can actually do that
because I know exactly what I'm bracing for
by even talking about this.
Make sure you're following the David Pakman
show on Instagram at David Pakman show.
While you're there, 12
me on instagram@daviddottacticthedavidpakmanshow